[Music]
if you think it can't get worse it can
and it will
the dying's not done the killings not
done I promised my crew a long time ago
I'd keep them alive
afraid you were dead where's the rest of
third time
we're it Sergeant Collier I'm your new
assistant driver tank school that's home
remember you've seen me inside the tank
you will I started this war killing
Germans in Africa now I'm killing
Germans in Germany then with these fine
gentlemen for years these troops could
buy you we got us you
I won't ask you do anything I haven't
done myself
[Music]
comm check photo check very change a
culture
and eels are peaceful history is violent
what do you see see what we're manga
dude another man I'm scared too will end
soon but before it does a lot more
people got to die well you know we do
get a dollar thirty five a day
the spider gets 300
[Music]
I'm gonna run now
[Music]
[Music]
they are the world's most deadly
assassin citizens
their identities or a secret
even from each other how's work we had a
little trouble with the Commission so
how's the Lana you look for a job or
something you are the job a few problems
ourselves did you do something new I
added peace ah peace I love my wife but
there are times there's this huge space
between us and it just keeps filling up
with everything that we don't save each
other shoot like that it's government or
something you just been identified by a
competing agent how are you gonna handle
it I'm gonna borrow this yeah sweetheart
love gets lethal if an unusual problem
Jane obviously won't be dead and I'm
less and less concerned for your
well-being so what do we do from the
director of The Bourne Identity come on
sweetheart come to Daddy
Angelina Jolie
[Music]
baby
mr. and mrs. Smith do you know that
you're ticking this is major Roy McBride
I'm attempting to reach dr. Clifford
McBride
this is dr. McBride son
dad I'd like to see you
I recall how we used to watch
black/white movies together musicals
were your favorite
I remember you tutoring me and math he
was tilden me a strong work ethic you
should know I've chosen a career that
you would approve of I've dedicated my
life to the exploration of space and I
thank you for that
[Music]
what is happening out there is a crisis
of unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead what exactly are you
implying for me
exploration is now is a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
[Music]
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
I'm Rick Dalton it's my pleasure
then mr. Schwartz call me Mom put it
down got your son no that's my stunt
double clip move I eat when [ __ ] hey
Rick Dalton double feature I love that
stuff you know that killing a lot of
killing
[Music]
[Music]
I'm stopping
[Music]
so you still direct bill here you can do
anything you want to
[Music]
I hired you to be an actor wick not a TV
cowboy you're better than that
alright what's the matter partner it's
official old buddy has been
[Music]
Here I am flat on my ass
whoo I got the next order me I'm Sharon
cake I'm in the movie you're in this
that's me
I play Miss Carlson the class
well there ain't no trees jalisco bacon
and the gospel
[Music]
[Applause]
in this town I can all change
hey you're it [ __ ] dog me don't you
forget it
[Music]
I want to ask you what part of the
country you come from originate from
Canada I guess where that is well I know
where Canada is I've been there myself
well traveled for a slave Solomon
Northup is an expert player on the
violin I was born a free man lived with
my family in New York be good for your
mother until the day I was to see to
Solomon kidnap sold into slavery Solomon
I'm a free man and you have no right
whatsoever to detain you no free man you
nut butter Georgia run away down to the
river
let's servant don't obey his Lord shall
be beaten with many stripes that's
Scripture the condition of your laborers
it's all wrong my property you say that
with pride I say it is fact Frank man
does how he pleases with his property
booth
you come here days ago I was with my
family in my home now you tell me all
this loss if you want to survive do and
say as little as possible
thought you knowed something I did as
instructed there's something wrong it's
wrong with the instruction master bocce
here work anymore I learned you a
hundred lashes I know what it like to be
the object of masses mash in his own
time tomorrow I'm not falling to despair
I will keep myself on it to feed on this
opportunity
I was a free man
I'm not a speck
[Music]
I fought many wars in my time some were
fought for land some for power some for
glory
I suppose fighting for love makes more
sense than all the rest
do you love her father you are a great
king because you loved all of Troy
that's the way I love Helen I want her
back when you go to war with my brother
they're coming for me
the wind is bringing them closer this
will be the greatest war the world has
ever seen
we need the greatest warrior
Tilly's can't be controlled be careful
King of Kings first you need the victory
I won't ask you to fight my war you
already have the loser will burn before
nightfall
immortality take it it's yours
no son of Troy will ever submit to a
foreign ruler then every son of Troy
shall die
now you know who you're fighting
is the no one else is there no one else
there are rich teams and there are poor
teams then there's 50 feet of crap and
then there's up welcome to open my jobs
take this team to a championship I need
more money
we're not New York we're not gonna
compete with 120 million dollar payroll
got your goal shouldn't be to buy
players your goal should be to buy wins
who are you here is 25 players that have
been overlooked by every other team for
one reason or another like an island of
misfit toys in here is a championship
team one that we can't afford
who's the good the kid is the new
assistant GM we're gonna shake things up
tell him you want me to speak when I
appoint you yes the new direction of the
open eggs we are card capitals at the
blackjack table we're gonna turn the
odds on the casino
you don't put a team together with a
computer Billy adapt to die Billy Beane
has come in and tried to reinvent the
system now it's just not working out
they call it Moneyball
I think that he bought a ticket of the
Titanic hey daddy you can lose your job
what well I go on the internet sometimes
well don't go in Internet watch TV you
talk to people do you believe in this
thing or not
I don't % listen up you may not look
like a winning team but you are one so
play like one tonight we're doing
something really unexpected and special
and at the whole city is feeling it if
we win this team we change the game for
good
this better work I'm just kidding
[Music]
all right you ready to do this that's a
bad dishwashing laughs well I got a
bunch of amateurs guess that's sort of
shortcut what you asked me to get you
it's gonna kill everybody in the wrong
[Music]
marked records game was hit a couple
nights
give it all up nobody gets hurt it's
only money
so where do we go from here we start
with traveling they are not gonna okay
anything major here was that me they
just want you to talk to
don't hurt him too badly because they
don't want to hurt let's have a beer
we got the two kids but entrance
bragging about how he just knocked over
this guy's game for honor okay
I don't know what is but these guys they
can't get the mouth shut about nothing
so we're gonna do it you and you Mickey
film New York Mickey I don't want you
over into a double I gotta hit I don't
know if they'll spring for two guys it's
a two-man job I come in here every day I
know I don't know if you guys know me
my position very few guys ever get in
you have choices
I don't know if I can do this I made a
mistake and you gotta make things right
killed anyone women cry please call some
others man I like to come softly from a
distance come up here to do something
remember I don't take orders with you
what you gotta do it right you know this
is a business of relationships don't
make me less
I'm living in America and in America
you're on your own
[Music]
[Music]